for the first time president biden has
expressed support for a ceasefire
in the israeli-palestinian conflict but
the violence shows no signs of letting
up early this morning
israeli forces launched a series of new
strikes
on targets in gaza that follows another
night of
heavy firing from both sides more than
200 palestinians have been killed
since the fighting started including 61
children 10 people including two
children have been killed in israel
mts on the southern israeli border
imtiaz good morning
anthony everyone good morning that's
right i'm here in southern israel where
we were brought
by the israeli military and this of
course is an area which has really
suffered
the brunt of hamas's rocket strikes now
the israeli military has showed us
what's known as the iron dome which is a
missile defense system
but first we start in gaza and a warning
some of these images are
hard to watch
[Music]
it's a conflict he has no way of
understanding
but will bear the scars of for the rest
of his life
five-month-old omer is cradled by his
father muhammad al-hadidi
the only family he has left after his
mother and four brothers were killed
in an israeli bombing pulled from the
rubble by rescuers
his tiny body is covered in injuries
including a broken leg al-hadidi returns
to the wreckage of what's left of his
home
he says israeli warplanes targeted my
family without warning
without calling them with no regard for
humanity or babies
across gaza and the scale of the
devastation caused by israel's bombing
campaign
is hard to fathom neighborhoods in ruins
hospitals at breaking point and vital
infrastructure
like roads water treatment plants and
telecoms are on the brink
according to the united nations gaza's
only power plant will likely run out of
fuel later today
potentially plunging the palestinian
territory into darkness
it's an uncertainty that's only bringing
more misery to an already desperate
situation
in israel and hamas rockets continue to
rain down
badly damaging this street in the
southern town of ashdod
injuring at least three people
more than 3 000 hamas rockets have been
fired into israel since fighting began
over a week ago the vast majority have
been intercepted by the iron dome
missile defense system
quite amazing the israeli military took
us to see the multi-billion dollar
technology
which is partially funded by u.s
taxpayers brigadier general daron says
without it israel would have suffered
far more casualties
this is really a life-saving system
what we are doing here is is purely
saving lives of israelis
[Applause]
but in gaza there are no such defenses
now earlier this morning israel has
allowed some humanitarian aid
and some aid workers into the gaza strip
a move that's being welcomed by the u.n
vlad
unbearably heartbreaking mti's thank you
very much